welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in Rick and Morty season 4 episode
2 the old man in the seats
turns potty humor into a sad reflection
on loneliness which is essentially what
every bathroom is it becomes for me once
again this episode is filled with clever
animation jokes and easter eggs that you
might have overlooked so let's sift
through the turds who analyze the
subtler details in a reminder to
subscribe to our Rick's plain podcast
feed for early audio versions of this
episode and my analysis of the deeper
darker truth of each episode that might
be as many things this episode are a
crock of [ __ ] like last episode 402
opens at a breakfast maybe a routine for
a season that promised to restore the
series to its each episode of standalone
adventure that season one was and now
those adventures could all begin with
the same origin point at the breakfast
table we meet glooty Rick's intern
voiced by director Taika Waititi he's
part of a race called the manag Tron's
monogamist water seekers who trick
species into developing chaotic dating
apps that take over their societies rick
has to use an intern because remember
he's no longer allowed to simply rope
Morty into all of his adventures and
tasks and glue Dee's name might be a nod
to gluteus maximus fear but muscle a nod
to blue tease often exposed ass and
really the overall poop joke of this
episode rick says he's headed on a solo
adventure one not directed by Ron Howard
a nod to Sol or Star Wars story but
really he's a shy pooper on his way to a
private toilet planet this is the
inspiration for this episode's title the
old man in the seat a riff on Ernest
Hemingway is the old man in the sea
which centers around a lonely old
fisherman who battles with an elusive
Marlin much like how Rick battles with
his elusive toilet stealer Tony this
episode this actually makes a second
Hemingway reference in the series
following Rick potion number 9 which is
also an episode about chaotic romantic
hookups I wish that shotgun was my penis
if it were you could call me Ernest
Hemingway's suicide choke so dark so
funny
Rick's toilet planet is a custom
designed utopia he blissfully brushes
his hands over the tall grass a not -
Ridley Scott shot of Maximus returning
to his heavenly home and gladiator the
design of this planet seems based partly
on Pandora in Avatar with luminous and
vegetation and floating rock islands
there's also this giant crystal on the
horizon on this week's episode of Rick's
plane I speculated how 4:02 might have
been masking the darker mystery of Rick
ex-wife Diane and we theorized how this
planet could have been Rick and Diane's
honeymoon location maybe that crystal is
a diamond from Rick's engagement ring to
Diane check our explain and keep an open
mind because I'll admit that's a bit of
a reach Rick investigates a broken twig
to sleuth out the intruder one of the
fauna options is this sloth-like
creature which reminds me a lot of the
prehistoric slot that shrugs at homer in
the treehouse of horror episode that was
just one little insignificant mosquito I
can't change the future right right
another possible cause is this falling
fruit maybe I'm reading into it but it
could be a meta nod by the writers to
the hold low-hanging fruit aspect of
this toilet humor joke episode but it's
something that the episode handles in a
really really smart way Rick makes a
guttural call to summon an antlered
creature cyborg it opens up a
subterranean lab in a tree trunk
I love how Rick's supercomputer uses a
Linux operating system because anything
else he uses the computer to analyze the
intruders stool reversing the digestion
to discover its original sandwich form
time to meet your maker
that maker got that sandwich from a frog
restaurant in the gorgon quadrants
organs have actually come up before on
the show and the ABCs of Beth episode by
Kiara's ex-boyfriend trend or nest
spread across 300 galaxies and you just
happen to pick this planet to hunt
that's dorgon's [ __ ] total Gorgon [ __ ]
Rick heads into the Prague restaurant
back room where it's operated by a fly
mobster named Verma Gerber he references
being a fly in charge of a frog gang
which feels like a backstory similar to
De Niro or Leodis characters and
Goodfellas half non Italian mobsters
rising high in an Italian gang but their
sandwich delivery guy is fighting in a
robot war with the Crocky BOTS one of
whom we saw in the indicators episode
last season Rick appears to the robots
in a funnel hat that has a QR code on it
actually if you scan this QR code it
actually takes you to the Rick and Morty
fansite shop where you can buy this
thing pretty clever marketing there but
you know it is just a funnel it doesn't
even have the handle like it does in the
episode so don't buy this the delivery
bodies looking for groats ance over his
function of delivery to make it
deliverance and when he gets shocked
they animated the inside of his head
with red gears to make it look like
blood I also just love the animation on
Rick's lottery in the Crocky BOTS he
curb stomps the first one he impales a
second he draws in
orders the third with cords that
skeleton tearing away from its skin the
Crocky bot leader has an Australian
accent which makes sense because
saltwater crocodiles are native to
Australia Rick uses a body shield fries
them all with a cyclops style optic
blast turning the tide of this battle so
robots are victorious we'll see if this
causes a lasting effect on the universe
since rocky bots were totally dulling
the win this from here rigged tracks
down the toilet thief
Tony voiced by Jeffrey Wright from
Westworld gonna hang look at a photo of
my wife while you'll kill me
sure but I'm doing her a favor she
either has terrible taste or she's
trapped in a marriage to a toilet thief
she's dead I don't mind joining her life
has been hollow since I lost her Rick
tells Tony not to use his dead wife as
an excuse and leaves him with a part
bomb that squeezes out a middle finger
of poo while all of this is going on the
B story centers around glue Dee's love
find her app to ours in a Z Jerry's
office contains a few Easter eggs his
Titanic poster from his experience in
the season 1 episode and a golfing
poster naughty new Jerry's golfing in
the meeseeks episode before I point out
another possible Easter Egg a quick
message from this episode's sponsor
which I shot when I was wearing a
different shirt so just deal with it
thank you to the sponsor of this episode
cats the mobile game where C ATS stands
for crash arena turbo stars but also for
cats the furry creatures that drive your
customized destruction machines
hey we trust them to play with our twine
why not trust them do pilot armored
vehicles with buzz saws build your
battle car with the wide selection of
weapons and chassis available in the
game you can even customize your cat
driver appearance by putting on
different outfits and hats the physics
in cats are fun and unpredictable every
two weeks you can participate in a new
game mode called the all-stars
competition that features modified
arenas the different battle conditions
like burning ground and low gravity make
sure to get the game now using the link
in the description below and enjoy a
very cool collaboration between cats and
toy brand Hot Wheels by participating in
the challenge you can collect iconic Hot
Wheels cars the game is available for
ios and android via a link in the
description download the game using this
link and get extra rewards that will
boost your progress thanks again to cats
for supporting this episode again both
the mobile game and the animals who are
some of our biggest fans because of my
milky complexion ok back to this episode
and back in the shirt also in this room
is a baseball
and hey maybe it's just a baseball but
last episode showed the sports bar with
a smith baseball jersey on the wall and
later this episode Jerry's dumb plans
feature a drawing of a baseball bat so I
don't know maybe they're setting
something up Jerry's equally dumb
alternative names to the app are you
love cupid er course love finders and
meat lovers and who got still love some
are uses this app at the mall food
courts connecting to new temporary
soulmates Danny she and Beth eat beside
restaurants with names like chick belly
flam's and toe Fung maybe like toe
fungus kind of like the gross gunk that
summers future lover picks off her foot
on the plane never take your shoes off
on a plane just don't do it summer and
Danny check into a motel if you look
closely the business card on the counter
reads blue ball the hotel's manager
Harry Lee bovitz I wasn't gonna find out
who Harry Leibovitz is in reference to
but blue ball motels time reflects how
these relationships get broken off
before they go anywhere and how Beth
here tries to blue ball them
she and summer scream over each other
assault and rape this could be kind of a
nod to that dark truth that they tell
women to just yell fire when they're
being assaulted or raped because sadly
that's more likely to get attention
Beth leaves Danny for a new partner Jeff
crashed in his wedding at the Sistine
Chapel like the one of the Vatican but
spelled like the gross skin outgrowth
the priests name is priest Witherspoon
love it and a series of wedding crashers
plays out like a rom-com parody like The
Graduate and Jerry Maguire you had me at
my own name Beth tries to stop it with a
hang glider
similar to the hang glider Rick used
during his orgy with unity if you crash
lands in a barn leading to my favorite
line of the episode how are you doing
parenting that's not how I did it yeah
where's your daughter hey you're right
nicest Rudy takes Morty and Jerry to the
monogatari on mother ship where his
leader is voiced by another New
Zealander anti Kuwaiti tea collaborator
Sam Neill the wife played by Kathleen
Turner you will not witness the true
power of superior intimacy for this line
in the dark hood and the throne he's
obviously a take on the Emperor from
Star Wars now witness the firepower
this fully armed and operational battle
station
Jerry pitches his plan to Morty which
includes an X through Rick's face and a
drawing of a sport again but their
neighbor able to do this plan glooty
frees them from the cell after Jerry
points out how unmatchable they both are
got a date was dumping a dating app was
that ever his thing no he never exited
that way first time while Rick deletes
Tony from a server the music here is a
boogie with the hoodies my [ __ ] but Tony
returns leaving bricks to operate a
giant mecha version of himself to punish
Tony
but just like susan sarandon therapist
character in a pickle Rick episode the
soothing voice of Jeffrey Wright has an
introspective monologue in store for
Rick - you need someone to give you
permission to live you know what shy
pooping is Rick it's a pointless bid for
control you want to take the one part of
life that you truly think is yours and
you want to protect it from a universe
that takes whatever it wants it took my
wife it clearly took something from you
but Rick's it's on him see me to crush
him but not synonym to toilet heaven
really he's just inserting Tony inside
this mecha structure and casing him in a
sack filled with global thin fluid that
projects your idealized dream kind of
like the reddish pink goo of the pods
the matrix
suspending all those people in an
alternate reality this case Tony's dream
is a toilet heaven almost an opposite of
the giant butt fart dimension that we've
seen before his wife is voiced by Pamela
Adlon who also voiced Bobby Hill on king
of the hill there are other people from
Rick's life that he has encased in those
sacks but for my theory I'm one of them
check out where explained this week Rick
sets a trap on his toilet tries to lure
Tony back with Fiber chili and sugar
free chocolates that will make him have
to poop but Tony's co-worker says that
he died skiing down Space Everest
oh no you don't eat that you'll you'll
become the opening of The Beverly
Hillbillies you know what I'm saying
little bubbling crude Texas tea
I don't know these references yeah but
you have a space Everest watch space
Beverly Hillbillies don't like jokes can
land
Rick's referring to the geysers of oil
in the opening of Beverly Hillbillies
this is likely a pitch by Dan Harmon and
the younger writers on staff just didn't
get the reference immediately Beth and
summer duel at the airports and love
finders starts using an ad wall leading
to everyone deleting the app one of the
ads is for the game tower offender which
I don't know if your minds in the gutter
like mine is it's kind of an
other blue balls joke there's also a
disinfectant that kills only 87.9% of
germs and after hugging it out with
jerry we learned that Beth's love
finders partner is Ted Danson at tony's
funeral Rick gives Tony's dad a ton of
money and a cloning machine in case they
wanted to make a new clone of his son
calling back the cloning device that
Rick used with Beth in the ABCs of Beth
episode and the final scene back in the
toilet planet now storm clouds have
gathered reflecting how this place is
transitioned from a sunny utopia to a
tragic lonely place now Rick pees over
the cliff because this toilet is no
longer for him to do his business it's a
throne upon which to sit and punish
himself for being isolated with no
companions
the Old Man and the sea and real quick
the post-credits scene shows Jerry
looking in the fridge and binding
globulin showing his pathetic dream
scenario of simply having a job and
feeling useful for a change delivering
Mountain sweats water and if you look
closely in the fridge beside a moldy
avocado there's that past the butter
robot that Rick built in the past
episode oh my god in a quart of milk
with a missing kids photo on the side
that is Morty's bully from the previous
episode who Morty elevated into the sky
do you think Rick will ever find
companionship comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at a vas and follow any rock
stars and socials and subscribe to our
explain podcast feed we're getting
closer to break into the top ten of TV
and film on Apple podcasts LAN helped us
beat Alan thank you for joining me see
you next week and if this episode smells
like [ __ ] it might also be because I'm
shooting this in front of a giant porta
potty
[Music]